see James puppies uploading a guy yes
good can I just say just before we start
this how much I respect you just
everything you've done no no seriously I
have to I think sometimes because you
don't know how much I respect you and I
value working with you without you I am
nothing I am this and you are that huge
or two men yeah but when YouTube first I
don't think you know this I had another
option and ultimately they reject him
exalt good enough then I'm not good
enough now I end up with you and I'm
just grateful for that because you've
you know you've let me just ride along
my every event you've had you've let me
you know every club yeah
stars of a line I suppose welcome the
true news
[Music]
so you may remember a couple of weeks
ago we did a live reaction to PF TV
check themselves a little bit too
seriously
[Music]
what funny all thing I'm taking that too
seriously up a lot what do you see the
other day true Geordie and Lawrence yeah
we saw our no bow for them yet mmm true
Geordie I respect that guys done it's
done some great things right what he's
done what he's achieved I have to say
that other guy that Lawrence don't know
what it is about that guy but he's just
a little rap
you're an animal rodent ironic what they
did it um which I didn't like is they
that part of the blood brothers way he's
talking you know you know to start of it
with Terry's talking yeah clouds a line
and this and that they've done that real
sort of parody years they tried to make
our lot we were being serious with it I
know yeah that was actually my fault
yeah because they blame me for that and
you you're deserving of respect somehow
so it was so funny when we were watching
yeah it actually did enjoy it the thing
is that was parody but the problem was
the actual job that we were mate and
generally was of how serious it was
taken yeah cuz there were fights on a
Sunday leaking yeah what sort of fitting
nicely and I did actually forget to
leave the little the parity bit this is
Joe yeah so sorry Robbie yeah that was
my fault somehow deserving respect
somehow a rat so let's just continue
with this they tried to make our lot we
were being serious with it I know
obviously it was you watch it it was
being done as a joke
yeah the fights were serious there was
two six-foot post men throwing leather
each other's face yeah HOD was this
whole it was a parody yeah we actually
both love that sure that's the funniest
thing about it I like him we love it it
yeah it's one of the better things on
YouTube correct as like DT and gore
bridge going head-to-head yeah football
right my audience are gonna laugh they
ate it off of this and enjoy it yeah
600,000 views promote the short of them
if I really hated something I wouldn't
even put it on my channel yeah I mean I
actually respect what they have made
that can I say this I respect the show
just because you take yourself seriously
doesn't mean that I have to take you
seriously
now he's Lucky's not a ruby of back in
the day Robbie used to be a quantity
surveyor he could have come over assess
my building and said all your mortgage
isn't worth as much anymore so that will
actually really pissed me off very lucky
that I reasonably from back in the day
because the old Robbie the old Robin
yeah sorted you right come over made my
building and then what Robbie is
insinuating here is he'd have beat the
[__] out of me so boys anyway that well
if you make fun of me I'm gonna beat you
up because that was always a smart way
to go
none you know me the smart people who
have got good arguments always go best
beat this guy for the record Robbie's
not gonna do now I don't know why it is
where this guy is always chatting about
me you know I'm you know I remember he
said oh also fan TV and that that will
never be any successful no sponsors will
ever touch it did you say that no no I
mean if you were miss Cory to me that's
what I said you got that completely
wrong yeah I was wrong there I'll admit
that I was wrong in in this fall
scenario I was wrong there okay then he
said I would nobody would want to do
anything with those guys how could I
ever get to TV I've got a TV program my
own production company nailed you in
your face it's fictional or it's had
have said arsenalfan TV you would never
go to show on TV
they didn't it was the other company
under that the name of which I can't
remember the show name I can't remember
same as anyone else having said that
credit to you for getting a TV show
that's fantastic good on you Robbie well
done well well done to you so you know
what keep hate you know yes got to keep
hating because every time he hates about
something and it gets bigger he's in a
lucky situation because for a guy a very
limited talent that's awkward isn't it
without of it hot yeah just rate yeah
which to be fair you don't rate him
particularly from a video making
standpoint he's entitled to his opinion
I think that that site what that's fair
enough if he doesn't really I don't
think you lose any sleep over that but
it's just not true as that now speaking
from experience working with Lawrence
yeah is there anyone in YouTube I know
he as funny as you on camera can edit
like you can produce like you can
like you parison create like you make
make millions laughs million I'll just
say yeah as a little bit of a sizing all
guns blazing yeah blood brothers yeah
why do all also fan TV show some like le
gang documentaries and not football gang
thing isn't it it's gang gang gang gang
yeah yeah as a presenter a guy of
limited talent riding off the back of
Geordi I'm sorry I think at this point
Robby's just on a run and he's not
actually talking sense he's talking
emotionally there yeah like when people
collaborate of course they benefit from
each other and like I collaborate
because you me best mate not because
like there's anything particularly in it
for us yeah like we just wanted to make
videos together like people could point
the finger at Robbie and go if you
hadn't had everyone running about with
anger would you be where you are if you
hadn't had Arsenal channel and he'd made
a Robbie channel would you be where you
are
if you hadn't had a troops tie Claude
would you be where you are obviously
that's not an argument with me and
because you've done it
regardless you've got where you are well
done I didn't realize when we were
having a laugh that we would have
actually like upset and this much and he
never meant to do that
we literally expected them to take the
piss back yeah and maybe challenged us
to a silly game of football with EXO
yeah I didn't think he would be this
hurt by you know I mean we didn't mean
to hurt his feelings I didn't think we'd
knit the nail on the head but every time
I see that guy you like Rob how's it
doing so when I see Robbie we're both
adults yeah so I go good see Rob you're
right you've Chancellor Mary Wallace
well done there mate I know I don't go
oh yeah oh you prick see ya just because
you don't necessarily love the content
that they're make doesn't mean you've
got a be an [__] I don't people can
go I can be critical of that but I can
also appreciate and respect that person
isn't that what normal people yeah I
mean we're friends with Melanie so what
does that say no offense well yeah we
love friendly fire but a guidance maybe
he's making his career offered just
sitting down we do sit down a lot he's
got a son that he's got us on that
yeah he's nailed us yeah yeah he's
sitting down as you seen that yeah
I don't think it makes you more talented
if you're standing okay no especially
while holding the microphone for someone
else absolutely so it doesn't matter if
you sit and don't understand enough can
we all agree on just a tip Robbie
we got microphone stands lovely yeah I'm
Lawrence he makes his thing off or just
sitting down and go I see now that is
exactly like have you ever seen a ghost
where Whoopi Goldberg channels Patrice
where's the ASB almost and that's not do
you know I mean I just became you yeah
yeah it's really good it's really really
good ah see done was he crazy what have
you created I mean it is ya know much is
suppose Robbie's not a subscriber to XO
[Music]
there was that but that one did you at
one time where I know that no nothing
the guy's got so much to say about
football when's the last football game
you went through eighteen eighty ninety
percent of your audience is a video by
DT you get 800,000 views yeah ninety
percent of that audience couldn't have
gone to a lot of fitted in the stadium
yeah I'm working the kickoff on the
weekend do you want me to go to the game
and not do a job either we're kind of
just see if you're from ourself on TV
that's a live show every weekend where
you can watch live football with us yeah
live reactions really fantastic show
it's a beautiful thing really great
you'll love it you'll love it tune in
just to be absolutely clear I'm using my
limited talents and not going to the
football and you can do that too with us
every weekend on the kickoff honestly
man I said nothing about this guys now
this is about two years never said
nothing about you before me I said
nothing about me before and roll the
clips I like true Jordy right but I
quite lost
it's like guys obsessed I don't know how
many games he goes I don't feel that he
goes to a gay easements as I said bad my
bad my big guy man there you go
he probably won't even understand that
so go look it up yeah but when you see
someone awesome what does bad Mike do I
understand the definition of a literal
phrase don't you know I've known a guy
from I know him from back in the day I
know that a couple of times he wanted to
do some stuff for us I don't is because
maybe we didn't use him or whatever what
what is this guy's problem man being
there cheating on us a hand in your CV
oh I caught you yeah I just said to him
there's a few things that I you know you
can change with the cameras or change
the graphics and I say if you need any
help give me a call
well Robbie's had his say fair play
entitled or what I mean in service I
thought you might say more about the
jokes in the video yeah and not just yes
strip at you thanks for the feedback I
have been a little bit critical of
Arsenal fan TV down the years and that
rightly so the content never of the
people never made it personal you know I
like Robbie I like DT all the guys and
they've been greatly since we've got a
good luck for dude
Dease you've been great and they've made
big numbers in that I think that's good
and that's good for everyone you you got
a for Robbie yeah
and I will say this the Robby I have a
little bit worried for you because you
do seem a little bit upset so you might
remember recently we were talking about
how most of the women on the richest
people in the world list are they from
divorces well right we've got another
lucky winner from the divorce lottery
her name is right what is it
Mackenzie Mackenzie Bezos yeah who
married a very intelligent right man who
started Amazon Jeff well done to him
it's a hard worker the one who went and
built the company he's now gonna get
half of that company that he worked for
because it divorce 137 million hundred
sorry I misread that billion dollars
earlier net worth so she's getting yeah
60-odd get a lot I mean good for her if
she gives it to charity not since you
don't deserve nothing yeah II live on a
billion she's maybe he's built the
company she's been writing books or some
[__] yeah right let us take the money
from the books give us some cash maybe a
billion anyone who thinks it's fair for
someone to just get half of your company
because they're married to you when
they've done nothing to contribute to it
is a [__] [__]
you think a quarter would maybe be more
reasonable a fifth I think if you're
lucky enough to be in the position of
being a billionaire yeah and you be
married a woman for 25 years and use and
she's supported you and building that
company I don't issues you get nothing I
don't think she should be in a position
where she could have to worry about
money but I don't think she needs a
hundred [__] million dollars or what
a billion dollars or whatever divorces
are a [__] job is this everyone's
worried about open and doors and [__]
paying for dinner how about my worry
about the real [__] people getting
making a living of getting divorced the
richest men in the world of CEOs of
companies that they built the richest
women in the world are the women who
divorced those men that's what's wrong
with the world right now if you want to
eat equality make your own [__]
fortunes don't worry about what men are
do well I'm worried about one day
Lawrence yeah as a woman is gonna get a
fifth of XO these days Stevens gonna get
married early and then we're gonna give
[__] half away to [__] what surface
well so as some of you may know mr.
Donald Trump mr. president Donna
assuming you may know President Donald
Trump fancies building a wall around
America between him in New Mexico those
people on the other side of the wall
he's got a little advice for you never
ever give up don't give up if there's a
concrete wall in front of you go through
it go over go around but get to the
other side of that wall so Mexico yes
you heard him he's gonna build a wall go
over it go around it get to the other
side yeah I present to you Donald Trump
now claiming he never said he'd pay for
the world
I said this I never said this I didn't
mean it literally when I said there paid
for the wall you said it a million times
yes so much he goes on to say they're
gonna pay through the wall through other
payments I'm gonna start doing the same
I'm gonna start going to the electricity
company can I pay you sort of kind of
money hobo acts of kindness yeah I'm
human hugs reminds me of a podcast guest
I almost type with that wasn't hugs Mia
Khalifa was supposed to be coming on the
potty a well-known porn star really well
she was a porn star she she ran out of
tugs to give you an on the podcast oh
yeah well yeah but can we talk about
appalled Korea got back there was she
born in fact talk about a porn career
right sorry the woman's famous for
taking loads to the face won't talk
about the thing that made her famous now
so what are we gonna talk about all she
likes sports
was she a sports person did she perform
as an athlete I mean some of the things
she did were pretty athletic I'm not
gonna lie here the interview isn't
happening I'm sorry everyone huh I
didn't want to chutzpah I don't even
want to chat sports with start my days
off that I love this I love the star of
it we've got Mia Khalifa here on the
podcast Mia I suppose what I think a
first one I think of you is what do you
think of Uriah Reni as a referee in the
mid-nineties ridiculous shite so
absolute ridiculous I treated this out
I'm sick of how the [__] Beurling I'm
having exactly
getting guests on yeah you know who's
what now sorted on us this is the life
I've got right now what rejected by Mia
Khalifa sent it by not accept welcomed
so many hugs ticket this is for you
because they don't know well yeah Tommy
Robinson brilliant absolute fantasy spec
the fight with it no man I said he you
can't put lipstick on a pig
Tommy Robinson welcome to this Java
genuinely Tommy's not a [__] happy
with us he told me this is on Instagram
you know Geordi told me he was scared
and that he used the term scared to try
and look Tommy I've stood next to you
you're a actual norm true Geordi told me
he was scared to get me on his podcast
in case people were offended that's not
what I said
that's not always actually right no no
Tommy either remembers this completely
wrong right or is just lying because I
set him for a [__] I have bills to pay I
have a sponsor to keep happy I can't
piss my sponsor off and have them remove
all funding for one [__] podcast with
Tommy Robert so no matter how much I
agree with your views we cannot have you
on Tommy so now I see this pop up on
Instagram these how to pop it is instead
I literally sent every crazy bus that
into my dear brightly early on I would
actually have a chat with Tommy on a
podcast probably but love I need it like
check the shits all right we respond we
need to cut me a few calls in service
might be coming on but not you might not
but the point is a woman who takes
Lourdes to the face it's not rejected me
right ricky gervais all too happy to sit
down with all true Geordie yes so you
don't know how many loads Ricky Gervais
is taking to the face I mean we'll ask
him in the interview I just want your
your view on this alright so apparently
Drake fungals and kisses 17-year old
girl in old concert footage Kiki do you
love me
are you overage with your passport to
prove
or your driving licenses except it's now
this isn't unusual for big celebrities
to do they'll get someone on stage
they'll give them a little I don't know
if that's a good idea
right especially when they look like
they might be [__] it in your mean
leave it oh I've got to say I find it
unusual that he would do this in front
of a crowd with anyone of any age 100%
yes you're a superstar what are you
doing why are you kissing a girl
oh he hasn't done anything laws he has
he just said I get in trouble for doing
this [__] and then he says how will you
she goes 17 and he's oh my god oh my god
son like I've seen comments under this
[__] saying drinks a penal drink is not
this is him making a silly mistake when
he was younger himself what was he like
22 23 steel breaking in law I think he's
done something silly but I don't think
that he is sinister he's not all Kelly
there's not gonna be a documentary
called surviving Drake made one of these
days well you never know nowadays
there's a documentary out right now
about are Kelly and what a [__] piece
of [__] he is and yet he's still
performing in nightclubs as if nothing
happened like he's just riding this wave
um I kind of just say kind of just say
right off Kelly can still see pedophiles
don't lose their super I don't know sees
a Peter I think is just an abuser from
what I understand with rappers yeah you
expect them to be up there no good to
some degree 50 cent all these bad man
rappers right yes I'd find it yeah go
look you're weirdly Chris Brown Drake or
Kelly like these are the guys who should
be the good guys they're telling love
songs right I mean and kind of trust
them no none of them know Natalie are
Kelly wasn't that big I believe I can
fly I hate that my dead uncle's funeral
they're great uncles whew
he's gonna be turning in his grave well
that's it he thinks that the whole world
is a [__] sweet shot yeah and he can
do whatever the [__] I'm sorry that was
a like taking candy from a baby
he just has no concept of what you can
and can't do you know it's everything's
allowed in his right
everything's allowed he's [__] there's
no way but tell oh yeah how is problem
you're a bad person or Kelly this is
short montage of just fat people
accepting that they're fat I love it are
you sure I knew this for a reason no I
just thought you need some TLC in your
life
Thanks American Network say what this is
this is what I'm talking about what
happened to the healthy bar that I told
you you could keep in your car in case
you away from your food I've actually
eaten them all I love her honesty I like
fat women as well especially I like them
a lot be honest have you ever liked
really not to this size of but the thing
in my head I always think greed yeah
greedy forfood greedy for women and this
is a sweeping general statement Bob
Gordon tends to anyway impulse control
and women yeah usually not in the same
sentence the [__] irony of you saying
that she's huge she's not an ugly woman
though she does look a bit like she's
wearing a fat suit she reminds me of
Rosie O'Donnell if Rosie O'Donnell sat
down for three years Wow she makes me
want to be sick
she really cuz imagine like smell of her
she'll [__] reek she's being an angel
this is really sad isn't it unless you
wash yourself with a loofah a sponge on
a stick
lie maybe a durable stick because it's
going into a lot of crevices so shopping
for her if not what she need to be
eating or she should be is about what
she might be and if you ain't got what
she won't see me it's not she's going
shopping and then I'm going get the
vergis if you lock the door on her what
is she gonna do who's gonna lie though
yeah she thought I would do what lock
the door right I just put stickers of
celery underneath the door
whiny lies put the sticks of celery in
front of it why do you eat your what
worries me those should probably eat her
own [__] completely your main worry was
somehow the right trailer to a [__]
radio or something idea I'll admit I
quite like the ace family yeah yeah they
seem like a happy bunch I do think they
broadcast a lot I mean clearly
while you taking a young girl into a
department aisle sex toys I'll be honest
we've all been in situations where kids
have gone write something funny and they
don't know what they're dealing and as
an adult you obviously laugh I don't
think the guy deserves to be locked up
for this now but it was a very stupid
thing he goes and buys hold a lollipop
yeah lollipop and you're giving that to
a child and that's just I just
fundamentally don't agree with sharing
children's lives on YouTube in a big way
fair enough if you're a parent and the
odd moment happens that you want to
share when you literally run a business
from share in your kids lives it's too
much jinan I mean and [__] like this
will happen when you share too much the
point is holding a message it's a
learning experience for him and anyone
else who wants to in my opinion they
come and sell their children's lives for
your own benefit if your child takes
hold of a dildo lollipop don't take
photos
Huber's each three hours he did this for
amazing took three hours this man did
this would that not that would terrify
would it you think that would terrify
you if you walk up and watch the CCTV
the next morning and seeing that would
you get it replaced this has also been
in the news this week now I know how
much you love Harry Potter what the [__]
this woman has basically trained her dog
and I'm being serious here this one's
trained her dog to react to spells not
that Natsu Buster didn't oh and her god
no oh okay so then she does all the
spells yeah and then the dogs learn Matt
Avada Kedavra yeah I mean credit to her
she's done well here hasn't she Falana
she's got her 5 minutes of fame people
get too wrapped up in their pets I don't
get me right have a pet yeah have a pet
that's fine
I'm sick you know give them treats when
your whole life becomes about your pet
yeah yeah do your life wrong you've done
to you you're [__]
yeah yeah like look after your salad
little bit for your woman go out get
your hair done you know just put some
makeup on get your son out where the
losses divin sit all the day wasting
your [__] life away on this
all news Wellington Phoenix DA Stephen
Taylor given the boot after sex to
Grandal why he was former Newcastle
player he was like oh I want to be John
Terry sort of thing he was terrible yeah
I follow Newcastle defender was dating
22-year old model
Diana Adam artists Ida mattis and flew
her to New Zealand in October last year
that's lovely the Sun reports Taylor 32
wrote thinking of you long pins you have
me smitten like a kitten or values 32
year old martyt old man [__] health
smitten like a Jesus sorry I can forgive
sure but smitten like a kitten
[__] off however I don't Matias was
devastated when an Australian model
message her revealing that she enjoyed
sex sessions the week before her visit
to waterfront penthouse your boyfriend
Steven Taylor is a piece-of-shit liar
why i was in wellington just before you
i was livid he odd he's obviously done
this before i feel so hurt I told him it
was over and he pleaded with me to given
up give him another chance I'll wear my
long pins it's mad though cuz she really
does have good legs like easy ease in
the legs for sure you think he's handled
these women much like used to handle the
Newcastle buck fault really badly
mismanaged right yeah okay is it do you
think he's not going come on guys
offside the offside or santosh of them
come on they used to call all the other
players long pins
come on long pins female UFC fighter
leaves Robert bruised and bloodied after
he tries to rob her using a cardboard
gun in Brazil she looks like a very
happy 20 apparent she's 26 yet she did
that to him oh yeah oh you [__] up me
that's all he had in his hand yeah this
guy just was not ready for this yeah I'm
so proud of her she's entitled to
absolutely she can give him a good
hiding yeah because he tried to rob her
feel sorry you know for poor people who
feel compelled to rob is to use violence
they deserve what happens to them good
news for our friend Robbie Williams he's
beaten Jimmy Page in his fight to and I
quote build a 30-foot subterranean pool
and gym yes congratulations you
multi-millionaire we're right behind you
while we love all Robbie's all Rob
easily especially the
and Robbie yeah there's only one people
Vint witness all week on when are you
gonna do a video about Robbie I'm saying
already already done the podcasts you
know you're not seeing it they said when
are you gonna go to that Robbie's house
and show how ridiculous and overblown
his house is because of all the money
he's made for all the ridiculous
controversy he's had in his life and I
go we've not been to Robbie
he didn't need any future study no did
it all himself did it all himself
yeah or hung rose on Kylie Minogue this
is Robbie Williams 46 room house which
the Daily Mail has taken his rhymes with
you bigger on the inside in the same way
that Robbie's heart is also bigger on
the inside he texted me the other day
new and gold bridges on foam bridge
found out that Robbie Williams watches
him I've already told it is weird that
it's such a general they say it's six
degrees of separation or whatever like
yeah everyone knows someone through
those six people or whatever yeah for
90% of the year yeah he's in LA right
someone needs to house it no one's gonna
burgle it with us there we will keep it
and if you need someone to play your
music as it's been accused that you did
sort of this man on the right here at
any page if you want someone to do that
for the other ten months of the year
that you're not there and more than
happy to go in it we've got the booths
yep got this I mean Robbie no problem
Brian a karaoke machine if you want to
we literally sing rock DJ ten months of
the year few orchids we did kids pretty
good so we could do that I just wanna
field you remember feels really love
yeah you know the word so you might
remember we watched a video a couple of
weeks ago called you where a man and a
woman who recently met really words of
how much they love each other
lovely I predicted this thing gonna last
you know I mean meeting at Whole Foods
isn't the basis for a great relationship
anyway they've deleted the video broke
up so I was right let's have a look and
see what other [__] she's been uploading
kind of like a form of socially
acceptable insanity she's actually a
good filmic other skill she's actually
just she makes some cool [__] like it
actually looks good watching me I mean
it's basically she just puts a super8
effect on everything him nah because
nobody angles likes me there's stuff to
what she's doing that she's got a bit of
talent yes I know that's a buzzword
right now but she ain't telling this
I've just learned not to question it
because it's always led me to exactly
where I needed to be but this still
doesn't come easily for me I'm just
thinking to be subtle you know how she's
always talking like this as if she's
just in a state of Zen that guy she was
with who was not on her level at all
just millivolts he just wanted a [__]
and bounce and he got bored of all of
this peace [__] and when she put the
video out he went she revealed that he's
he's willing to go along with any old
[__] there just again his haul Wow
probably more Thank You Bernard she even
finds sirens peaceful there me distress
you are maitika well this is annoying
this is annoying me right it's just hard
it's gonna click it and see what it is
plenty falls so plentiful soul okay this
is a [__] brand let's see what she's
selling what is coexist an online
community for beautiful humans sorry I
don't know if you're welcome Brian who
want to learn to love themselves against
creating the iPhone
good of it I'm kind of interested she
just doesn't want to get a job I think
that she just wants to keep on making
like peaceful videos and just she just
needs you guys to fund it please turn
the video I mean this is lovely you know
it's really nice look now she genuinely
makes [__] that looks good
I look into this rod and I feel like I'm
the only one thank you so much
I do wonder if she's well I look into
this world and I feel like I'm the only
one seeing through so much they're
lovely little chimes in the wind and all
that in this all's nice it looks
beautiful but what do you actually
identify the words cooler over mouth you
realize it's pure bollocks she makes you
feel something and you know what I've
got to give her credit for that because
there's a lot of YouTube creators who
don't make you feel anything and I'll
give a credit for that I like that I
just don't know if I could I don't like
it productized it makes me feel
uncomfortable now I just feel like we're
promoting a brand rather than a woman
she seems like the type of woman you
know who would you sort of wake up next
layer in the morning and you'd look down
and all of a sudden they'd be like loads
of blood in the sheets and she'd go I'm
free bleeding that was the true news was
it you never know what's coming next on
this show this is the best [__] on
YouTube don't tell me it's not if you
want you can do so in the comments below
cuz everyone's the title of their
opinion loss
do you want to live in a plant-based
society well now is your chance to head
over to Jersey doctor at UK forward
slash plant-based to find out what Brian
eats on a weekly basis you can sign up
for your nutrition plan in the
description below click the link down
there just forty-four dollars a month
wait for the plant that's a [__] Bob
the plant-based thing and it'll send you
through to a great website he's gonna do
it if you don't want to murder animals
any more than this is the site for you
absolutely go murder plants instead
thanks a lot for joining us this week
enjoy everything if you don't like us
then you're entitled ooh yeah but also
you can go [__] yourself thank you
subscribe thanks for watching we'll see
you later hopefully if you are indeed
plant-based or not or not you know